what happens to 300 us dollars when they  are put through the clockworks the first  hundred dollars was put through on the  setting course it produced a puddle of  ink and a pile of cotton and plastic all  in all the material weighed about the  same amount as the original stack of  cash the second hundred dollars was  placed in the machinery set to one to  one it produced 75 euros in cash the  third hundred dollars run through the  machine on the setting fine produced a  shareholder's note for soap from corpses  products in the amount of 100  long story short it probably isn't a  good idea to try to use scp-914 to  increase the value of one's money